It's almost impossible to end a hit show in
a way that makes everyone happy.
But thanks to rushed execution, frustrating
character choices, and other inconsistencies,
a number of diehard Game of Thrones fans are
pretty annoyed with how everything shook out.
Here's a spoiler-filled examination of what
we think went wrong with the final season
of Game of Thrones.
For the first five seasons, showrunners David
Benioff and D.B. Weiss were able to mostly
follow Martin's books as a direct template,
and many of the show's most beloved and infamous
moments, including the execution of Ned Stark,
and the Red and Purple Weddings, were directly
out of the source material.
Benioff and Weiss did make some welcome adjustments;
in the fifth book, Tyrion wanders around for
what feels like years before meeting Daenerys,
whereas in the show, they team up pretty quickly,
but for the most part, they stuck to the literal
script in front of them.
However, once the show's fifth season ended,
so did the source material; the next book
in Martin's series, The Winds of Winter, is
still unfinished.
And once Benioff and Weiss ran out of source
material, that's around the same time many
fans started complaining about being unsatisfied
with the handling of the show's overall story
and writing, even though Martin himself guided
them through the final acts of the series.
Obviously Benioff and Weiss aren't without
talent, since they built the show fans grew
to love.
But Martin is naturally better at manipulating
his own story, and problems began to arise
when the showrunners were left to their own
devices.
It's understandable that, as Game of Thrones
went on and became a bigger and bigger hit,
HBO would want it to continue as long as possible.
But in 2015, Benioff and Weiss had a public
dispute with the network over how long it
would run, expressing a desire to close out
the show after just seven seasons.
Even though Martin himself said the show should
be at least 13 seasons, the showrunners and
HBO eventually forged a deal for an eight-season
run that would abbreviate seasons seven and
eight; the former would last for seven episodes,
while season eight would only consist of six.
Many fans critical of the show have come to
proclaim that cramming years' worth of buildup
and anticipation into a shorter set of episodes
created a new set of problems, making it all
the more baffling that the showrunners insisted
on these short seasons.
Without room to let the story breathe, the
final batch of episodes felt really rushed.
As a result, they stand in stark contrast
to the show's earlier seasons that focused
on epic journeys, character development, and
long throughlines.
As the eighth season began with two slower
episodes that harkened back to the show's
past, viewers got excited, but then it started
barreling towards its grand finale, letting
narrative threads come up short in confusing
ways.
Characters jumped in and out of the story
at breakneck speeds, like Bronn's sudden appearance
and disappearance from episode 4 being just
one example.
Seemingly insurmountable obstacles were overcome
in the blink of an eye, like the long-awaited
war with the Night King.
And characters seemingly teleported across
the map of Westeros when most of the early
seasons of the show were literally about how
long it took to get anywhere.
Fans knew Game of Thrones had to end eventually,
but no one wanted it to feel like it was trying
to get there as fast as possible.
With so much to wrap up, it's ultimately disappointing
that the showrunners let their characters
and plots suffer on the road to the finish
line.
The biggest and most unfortunate side effect
of the rushed pace of Game of Thrones' final
season is that while some of the plots and
developments were exciting and welcome, their
execution left something to be desired.
While there were plenty of issues to tackle,
Daenerys' battle strategies, Missandei's exit,
Euron's temporarily impeccable aim, Cersei's
maybe-real pregnancy, or how Bran became king
after doing basically nothing for the entire
season, the worst example is Daenerys' sudden
pivot into madness.
After seasons of barbecuing her enemies and
conquering lands beyond Westeros, fans were
anxious to see if Daenerys would follow in
her father Aerys' footsteps and become the
In the end, it makes sense that she did; audiences
have been tracking Daenerys' vengeful, unhinged
impulses right from the beginning.
But the only clear buildup viewers got for
Daenerys' full-on descent into insanity was
her enraged reaction to Missandei's death.
For a character who was always committed to
justice, some felt it was unearned to let
her torch thousands of innocents in King's
Landing.
Instead of letting Daenerys experience a complex
and fascinating character arc as she succumbs
to the madness she once so feared, the show
did her slow, steady growth to that point
a disservice, and arguably made a mockery
of one of its best and most interesting characters.
Daenerys' quick heel turn to Mad Queen is
certainly one of the most obvious examples
of season eight's uneven character development,
but she's not the only character to suffer
during the final season.
If you want to know where season eight went
wrong with its characters, look no further
than Jaime Lannister.
Jaime started Game of Thrones off in a pretty
bad spot, morally speaking.
Y'know, trying to kill a little kid because
he caught you having sex with your twin sister
is definitely frowned upon.
"The things I do for love."
But over the course of the show, he became
a fan favorite, thanks to a redeeming character
arc and an utterly charming performance from
Nikolaj Coster-Waldau.
Most of Jaime's redemptive streak was thanks
to his friendship and eventual tryst with
Brienne of Tarth, who loved the man beneath
the armor and helped him escape the clutches
of his conniving, cruel twin sister.
However, after sleeping with Brienne, Jaime
deserts Winterfell, which he risked his life
to save in the battle against the Army of
the Dead, to return to his sister's side.
So why's he suddenly leaving to go be with
his supervillain lover?
Jaime's only explanation:
"She's hateful, and so am I."
Some fans got their hopes up that he might
actually be returning to King's Landing to
kill his sister.
But in the end, Jaime and Cersei reunited
just to die in each other's arms.
With this one move, it's not hard to argue
that Benioff and Weiss undid years of character
development, giving one of the show's biggest
characters one of the least satisfying conclusions
they could have chosen.
And let's not forget about the other half
of this pair of doomed dummies.
Cersei, one of the show's most fascinating
and twisted characters and ostensibly one
of the biggest threats to the show's heroes,
spent much of season eight drinking wine and
idly staring off a balcony, only to suffer
one of the series' most anticlimactic deaths.
It may make a certain kind of sense for she
and Jaime to be reunited in their last moments...but
seeing the show's most cunning and cutthroat
villains get taken down by a pile of falling
rocks is just plain unsatisfying.
And this points to another big issue with
the show's final season: failing to pay off
on the series' many years of buildup.
One of the major strengths of Game of Thrones
was always its effective tension-building,
and fans were excited for huge storylines
to come to a head in the show's final season.
Make no mistake, season eight had plenty of
drama, but there were still several plots
that ended up with some pretty lackluster
payoffs.
Another obvious example is the Night King,
built up throughout the show's run as a formidable
villain who can raise entire armies of the
dead with a flick of his wrist.
Seeing Arya swoop in and take him down might
have been extremely fun in the moment, but
in the end, the entire narrative of the Night
King and the true history of the White Walkers
was left largely unexplained.
Meanwhile, the show spent seven seasons building
to the revelation that Jon was a secret Targaryen,
but threw it all out in the series finale,
giving the throne to a boy with no claim to
it whatsoever.
Season eight had some satisfying moments,
but ultimately, it suffered from a huge amount
of buildup that simply didn't pay off.
On the subject of lots of buildup without
much payoff, right from the beginning, Game
of Thrones was rife with prophecies, focusing
on everything from world saviors to poisoned
wombs and fateful deaths.
Since some of the prophecies came true during
the show's run, like the prediction made to
Cersei regarding her marriage and children,
it stood to reason that the rest of the prophecies
introduced would end up being extremely important.
Turns out, this wasn't the case at all.
With most of the show's prophecies abandoned
by the final season, it's hard to understand
why they were ever introduced.
"Stannis was not the Prince who was Promised,
but someone has to be."
One of the earliest prophecies made in the
series concerns Daenerys and her child-bearing
capabilities, which is made by a vengeful
witch who tells Daenerys that, more or less,
she will never be able to produce any heirs.
Daenerys fully believes this, telling Jon
as much and treating her dragons as her children,
but in the end, Daenerys' fertility had as
much importance as Ed Sheeran's bizarre cameo.
Daenerys was also a possible contender for
the seemingly all-important theories about
Azor Ahai and the Prince or Princess who was
Promised, but in the end, those prophecies
also fizzled into nothing.
Again, it makes sense that the series would
make some cuts to the narrative as it honed
in on its final episodes, but after seasons
of repeating these prophecies, seeing them
come to nothing is a disappointment.
Along with moments that ended up happening
offscreen, plenty of plots from the previous
seasons ended up on the cutting room floor.
While not completing every single narrative
thread on Game of Thrones is understandable,
it feels wrong that so many huge developments
ended up having little to no bearing on the
show's eventual conclusion.
For example, Jon Snow went through quite the
journey throughout the series, becoming a
strong and honorable man who literally died
and came back to life for his people, all
before realizing his whole identity was a
lie told to protect his life.
But in the end, none of that mattered at all,
since the show shunted Jon back into the Night's
Watch without letting most of Westeros find
out there was another heir to the throne.
Arya spent two seasons training with the Faceless
Men, and while she might have picked up the
stealthiness and weapons training that allowed
her to take down the Night King, it seems
odd that she didn't face-swap once during
the final season.
These examples are just scratching the surface;
after placing so much emphasis on the religions
of Westeros in previous seasons, from the
Red Priests and Priestesses to the Old Gods
and the New, those were all basically thrown
out and forgotten by the show's end.
Some plots were likely sacrificed for a reason,
but this many feels kind of ridiculous.
It would be impossible to include every single
character that ever appeared on Thrones in
the final season, but it's frustrating that
a few big names were left out entirely, especially
when comparatively new and altogether annoying
characters like Euron Greyjoy were allotted
plenty of screentime.
"I'm the man who killed Jaime Lannister."
Shut up, you idiot!
Anyway, considering how important Bran turned
out to be in Game of Thrones' final episodes,
it feels really wrong that Meera Reed, the
faithful companion who dragged him through
the far North and saved his life several times,
never showed up again.
Other faces entirely absent from the final
season are Daario Naharis, Daenerys' loyal
mercenary and onetime boyfriend, and Arya's
assassin mentor Jaqen H'Ghar, both of whom
seemed to have unfinished stories left to
tell.
And after a chance meeting in season seven,
Arya's rogue wolf Nymeria is never relevant
again.
We'd have traded any of Euron's scenes for
some of these forgotten favorites to show
up again.
"I'm going to put a prince in your belly!"
No, seriously dude, shut up.
One of the biggest questions of the final
season was who would actually rule over Westeros.
Ultimately, the question of who would physically
take the Throne was tossed in the garbage
when Drogon, after finding Daenerys dead,
torched the chair out of existence.
But the fact remained that the Seven Kingdoms
still needed a leader, and soon.
The Seven Kingdoms didn't exactly end up with
a leader, the Six Kingdoms did, after Sansa
demanded independence for the North and became
its queen.
The new king of the rest of the kingdoms ended
up being none other than Bran Stark, who seemed
to already have a full-time job staring into
space.
As with Daenerys' descent into madness, Bran
becoming king makes some sense in the context
of the show overall.
But to many fans, how it arrived there feels
basically absurd.
Tyrion argues that Bran should be made king
because he had the "best story" of all.
But let's remember that this character is
sitting between his two sisters with way more
interesting stories and actual leadership
skills.
Sansa became the badass Ice Queen in the North,
while Arya transformed into a super-assassin
and literally saved the entire world.
But sure, let's give the crown to the kid
with mind control powers who just sat there
and did nothing to beat his mortal enemy,
the Night King.
At least they didn't give their new king a
really insulting nickname or anything, right?
"All hail Bran the Broken...All hail, Bran
the Broken!"
Ummm, well...never mind.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.